ich bin auf der Suche nach der perfekten
Pasta seitdem ich selbst koche habe ich
festgestellt eine wirklich gute Pasta
kannst du lange suchen egal ob im
Supermarkt beim Lieferservice oder sogar
im Restaurant wenn du sie dir selbst
kochen willst kannst du dich auf eine
lange Suche nach wirklich guten
italienischen Zutaten und der perfekten
Nudel einstellen und mal ganz unter uns
meine erste Carbonara sah auch lange
nicht so gut aus schon vor zwei Jahren
wollte ich das ändern ich habe mir ein
Produktentwickler gesucht mit ihm
gemeinsam Soßen entwickelt und erste
Tests gemacht das Ergebnis ich muss
leider ganz ehrlich sagen da war nichts
dabei aber diesen Sommer habe ich eine
Nachricht bekommen die alles ändern
sollte also Folge pastapoesier um nichts
zu verpassen denn ab diesem Zeitpunkt
konnte ich sagen